there's always room for dessert here's a  sweet idea just for you  hey drew it's liz of e-cake be merry and  i want to share with you an easy cake  decorating tip let me show you how to  create this beautiful blossoming cake  first you'll want to take two piping  bags and cut off the side of each tip  then use food coloring to tint some  buttercream pink and fill a piping bag  push the buttercream all the way down  and make sure it comes out  let's do that again with some green  color it and fill the bag  looks good  grab the pink buttercream and pipe a  curved shape petal  continue to pipe a ring of petals all  the way around the cake  now move closer towards the center and  pipe a smaller ring of petals  take some gold sugar pearls and fill the  center of the flower to mimic stamens  grab the green buttercream and pipe just  a few leaves  let's take it for a spin